eat and sleep right basketball and won
and like that's like all I did for like
a good two years I was hanging off my
roommates we'd stay up four or five a.m.
and then be like who wants to go to
McDonald's and like all right it's down
the street yeah and no Nuggets Co
sausage Egg McMuffins actually nice
breakfast menu I'd say I know you're a
real web player it's up breakfast manual
Julie it's dark he would eat the
breakfast and then like half an hour
later you fall asleep and that's not
what you want to do like
you can I think this is like the most
boring episode of these ten videos but
your story is probably like the most
common of all of them yeah I mean I
guess like I don't have anything special
because I was thinking man I wonder if
they asked me to do this
what would my story be like what would
be that one big thing and I don't know
if I have that one big thing but like
you said I feel like I'm kind of just
like everyone else that plays well you
know they they've gone through each
expansion like from the beginning a lot
of them kind of feel the same way of
like I think I should stop like I
there's no reason to keep going every
time you feel like you hit the end point
of this game and of what they have and
you're just like oh what am I gonna do
jump around and ogum are some more on
the mailbox like I wasted so many hours
it's hitting spacebar spacebar spacebar
and after Cataclysm or like mid
Cataclysm they started making it kind of
even more casual than it was before it
was like you could look for raid you can
just do all these things and half the
rate could be afk and for me that's kind
of the point where I was like well this
game isn't what it used to be right it
wasn't as hardcore I hate to use that
word but it wasn't the same while that
it was before it was too easy I felt
like they were I know why they did it
cuz they're trying to grab a bigger
audience but that kind of turned me off
from the game because I would I would be
doing that looking for a thing and my
buddy that was there I'm watching like
numbers and charts and stuff like that
like DPS meters whatnot and he's like at
a couple thousand and I'm like what are
you doing is that all I'm eating I'm
like wait what do you mean you're eating
and I'm like okay I guess this is the
point where this game isn't the game
anymore so if you come back for every
expansion pack then as well I I went
through everyone except mr. fender which
was the last one that was the time when
I would I put the foot down and was like
nope never again this game had
sucked away too many in my hour is too
many my dollars it's like I'm never
gonna come back so what happened we went
to Blizzcon
like Blizzcon is a great event it's it's
a great place for Blizzard to show case
all their new games and whatnot but what
it really is is its community and what
it is is all the it's mainly Wow a lot
of the wow people that play the game
together this is their opportunity to be
like this is our spot and that and that
is powerful that is amazing when we had
the couple remember I think it's number
three right and we had the couple over
just listening to their story and their
trials and tribulations of what they
went through like from original Wow as
like progressively and then after the
fact after I'm like yeah twin amps at
between average but I know exactly what
that's like and I remember telling them
like kids these days don't even know
what it's like to have to walk from the
graveyard all the way back to to
announce that in itself with 30 minutes
you know and a lot of this game for me
which is I don't know how it is for
everyone else but it was a very social
thing right
have a conversation and you're playing
the game but you're really almost
hanging out more than you're playing the
game that sands like doing a raid or
like doing a dungeon or something like
that that started to dwindle to like you
all like people just stopped playing and
that once they people stopped playing
it's like what am I gonna do now but for
me really this game will teeter off the
same way I think for a lot of people
when I either a run out of content to
really do or be when I see the drop off
of my friends everyone comes back
everyone comes back you see your friends
list is blowing up 20 30 people and use
one month seven two months five three
months it's like three four months it's
like oh you're like the last one left
and you're just like well I guess it's
time because that's just kind of how it
is it's a cycle right